mona corona corona es steht einem bis
hier meine damen und herren wie wär's
denn mal mit dem thema das gute laune
macht was weiß ich so was wie schokolade
ja die kleine carlitscheck möchte bitte
aus der groko abgeholt werden schokolade
lecker aber jetzt kommt auch deprimiert
ja keiner tatsächlich keiner der
marktführer kann schokolade heute ohne
armut oder ohne kinderarbeit garantieren
nur acht prozent des weltweit
produzierten kakaos werden unter fairen
bedingungen geerntet schokolade sehr
gutes beispiel warum wir in deutschland
endlich ein lieferketten gesetz brauchen
dass unsere firmen verpflichtet
verantwortung für
menschenrechtsverletzungen und
umweltschäden in ihrer lieferkette zu
übernehmen jetzt kommt die gute nacht
nach jahrelangen streit hat sich die
bundesregierung endlich auf einen
kompromiss geeinigt und der ist quasi
super geworden weil weil es uns gelingen
gelungen ist die interessen des
menschenrechtsschutzes so voranzubringen
dass die berechtigten interessen der
wirtschaft dadurch nicht geschmälert und
beeinträchtigt worden sind mit anderen
worten das gesetz kannst du wegschmeißen
schutz von menschenrechten der nichts
kostet
es klingt ein bisschen wie abnehmen mit
der neuen mayonnaise diät tatsächlich
hat die groko auf druck von
wirtschaftsverbänden dem gesetzentwurf
so bearbeitet dass man ihn kaum noch
wiedererkennen beispiel er sollte mal
für firmen ab 250 beschäftigte gelten
jetzt greift es erst ab 3.000 und das
auch erst in zwei jahren gut hat den
vorteil dass einige kinder auf den
kakaoplantagen bis dahin volljährig sind
außerdem wurde die zivilrechtliche
haftungsregeln gestrichen das heißt
übersetzt klagen von geschädigten aus
dem ausland sind praktisch chancenlos
aber muss wer global gewinne macht nicht
auch global verantwortung tragen nein
viel zu teuer
die eu-kommission hat berechnet wie viel
eine solche regelung ein großes
unternehmen kosten würde
durchschnittlich etwa 0,005 prozent vom
jahresumsatz genau null komma null
0 5% oder wie wir im rheinland sagen
köln hinter karl spitz diese staffel
ich bin sehr stolz also homöopathischer
einbußen werden dass und trotzdem ist im
wirtschaftsrat der cdu selbst das total
verwässerte gesetz immer noch zu viel
die nennen das ernsthaft ein links
ideologisches projekt so so der kampf
für menschenrechte ist also linke
ideologie gut zu wissen ich möchte mal
ganz unideologisch festhalten ein
geschäftsmodell das auf kinderarbeit
basiert ist überhaupt kein
geschäftsmodell
vielleicht könnte der cdu-wirtschaftsrat
ein fachmann schnupper praktikum machen
zb bei der kakaoernte angelis seite
sitzt sein kleiner bruder
er geht gar nicht mehr zur schule sein
vater musste sich entscheiden für den
einen oder den anderen die ja klar
beide kinder zur schule schicken das ist
links ideologischer 51 umso trauriger
dass unser lieferketten gesetz in der
jetzigen version sogar hinter die
standards der un kinderrechtskonvention
zurückfällt deutsche profite durch
billigen es in kauf nehmen von
ausbeutung und das betrifft nach wie vor
klamotten aus asiatischen sweatshops
logisch aber auch ihren morgendlichen
kaffee aus äthiopien
ja klar für jeden von uns arbeiten laut
einer studie der uni regensburg im
schnitt 50 sklaven das gleiche ich nicht
aus mit einmal die woche fairtrade
bananen kaufen hier idee das neue un-
fairtrade siegel für mehr transparenz
wenn man sich zb sag mal so ein geiles
neues smartphone kauft dann klebte ein
siegel drauf dass für dieses smartphone
benötigte kobalt wurde von einem
teenager in deinem alter aus einer mine
im kongo gekratzt erzählt das mal deiner
doofen whatsapp gruppe und wo wir gerade
bei unfair sind es ist total unfair dass
in der traurigen rest version des
gesetzes firmen nur noch für ihrem
direkten zulieferer verantwortlich sind
alle zulieferer davor müssen sie nicht
mehr proaktiv kontrollieren sondern nur
noch anlassbezogen mit anderen worten
weggucken wird belohnt
schade in der ersten fassung war es noch
richtig gut das gesetz
nicht zuletzt dank gerd müller unser csu
entwicklungsminister kämpft seit jahren
so engagiert gegen ausbeutung man hat
das gefühl der mann ist im falschen
partei körper gefangen
überlegen sie mal obwohl er in der csu
ist christlich und sozial
mit anderen worten brandgefährlich die
deutschen arbeitgeber warnen vor diesen
scheinbar netten älteren herrn er sagt
knuffige sachen wie wir dich aber nicht
denn gerd müller ist ein gefährlicher
links ideologe er stellt sich in den
bundestag und sagt ungeniert klar für
uns die reichten genau wert mit anderen
worten wir sichern 80 millionen
arbeitsplätze
weil sich der kakao nicht von alleine
erntet unterstützen sie das engagement
der deutschen wirtschaft gegen kinder
arbeitslosigkeit das sos kinderdorf
vielen dank
gerd müller kein wunder dass er im
herbst aufhört der passt einfach nicht
mehr zu seinem verein aber der kampf um
ein besseres lieferketten gesetz geht
weiter teile der wirtschaft wollen ist
ganz weg haben
und wenn sie zu hause das auch ärgert
dann schicken sie bitte einen
lieferketten brief an ihren zuständigen
bundestagsabgeordneten näheres dazu
unter what the [ __ ] bei heute.de was man
allerdings zugeben muss rein
handwerklich war die schon toll gemacht
diese gesetz entkernung wie geht so was
herzlich willkommen zu die heute-show
logitech mit gürtel und dem oli
[Musik]
hallo liebe bastelfreunde heute basteln
wir uns ein prima lieferketten gesetzt
das irgendwie nach menschenrechten
klingt aber der wirtschaft kaum noch weh
tut
eine super sache und ist es ganz einfach
als erstes brauchen wir dazu natürlich
einen handelsüblichen peter weil so ein
peter kannst du als wirtschaftsvertreter
immer anrufen
zum beispiel weil sie nicht wenn den
gesetzentwurf mich passt wirklich jeder
zeit ruft ihn an und der peter kommt
vorbei ob mit dem fahrrad dem
hubschrauber über das was ganz egal
und genau so war es beim lieferketten
gesetz allein zwischen dezember und
februar hatte der peter telefonate und
videokonferenzen mit dem
hauptgeschäftsführer gesamtmetall dem
präsidenten und dem hauptgeschäftsführer
der bundesvereinigung der deutschen
arbeitgeberverbände nochmal mit dem
hauptgeschäftsführer bda dem präsidenten
des bundesverbands der deutschen
industrie dem hauptgeschäftsführer des
handelsverbands deutschland hde und dem
hauptgeschäftsführer des deutschen
industrie und handelskammertags dass der
dafür überhaupt die zeit der ist doch
wirtschaftsminister
naja und nicht nur das und jetzt bin ich
hier in oldenburg grünkohlkönig und das
freut mich und das ist der höhepunkt
meiner politischen karriere um grünkohl
muss er sich auch noch kümmern
kein wunder dass die november hilfen
jetzt erst ankommen
also du brauchst einen grünkohl minister
und diesen onkel hans michelbach spielt
eine ganz entscheidende doppel rolle
denn der csu mann ist vize vorsitzender
des parlamentskreises mittelstand der
unionsfraktion und gleichzeitig im
präsidium des handelsverband deutschland
hde ja einer von 28 wirtschaftsverbänden
die gerade einen geharnischten protest
brief zum lieferketten gesetz
geschrieben haben das heißt kann sie hat
also als wirtschaftslobby ist bei sich
selber gegen das gesetz protestiert und
fordert inzwischen es ersatzlos zu
streichen
ein glück dass wir in letzter zeit so
viel über lobbyismus geredet habe ich
versagt folgenlosen umso lustiger was
der doppelagent der kinder ausbeuter
erst letzte woche zum thema web
hat gesagt hat dass darauf auch in der
zukunft in dieser form nicht mehr
stattfinden und wir müssen alles dafür
tun dass lobbyismus auch mehr in frage
gestellt wird
[Gelächter]
schade schade es war so ein schönes
gesetz lieferketten gesetz aber jetzt wo
michelbach und große ordentlich
aufgebohrt haben
er ist nur noch milch übrigen richtig ja
nicht zuletzt übrigens auch dank dieser
frau die seit letzten sommer immer
wieder persönlich mit spitzen der
wirtschaft über lieferketten geredet hat
gesprächswünsche von gewerkschaften und
angeles wurden fast immer abgelehnt aber
die wirtschaftsverbände haben den
direkten natürlich sie hat für jeden
sogar ein eigenes telefon und einen
eigenen klingelton wenn zb der bdi
anruft
cool wirte schneider
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
wie laminat die freimaurer staatsführung
ist alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekanntgeben
erst bei so vielen abonnenten auf
youtube also ich würde mich ran halten